[موسيقى]
أعيد فتح باب الصين للتو بعد
ثلاث سنوات، لذا فإن غالبية المسافرين
القادمين إلى المنطقة هم أغلبية
الشركات التي تختلف تمامًا عن
الترفيه وعندما يأتون يجلبون
موظفيهم، فهم يجلبون
البنية التحتية بأكملها،
لذا فإن السفر الصيني هو  يتجهون بالتأكيد
نحو ما قبل السرية ولكن ليس إلى هذه
المنطقة، ومع ذلك
فهم الآن يعودون كثيرًا إلى
نقطة الترفيه الساخنة، لذا إذا كنت تنظر إلى
الأماكن الديموغرافية الترفيهية مثل
اليابان وكوريا وتايلاند وماليزيا، فإن كل هؤلاء
الرجال يحصلون على موجة من
من ناحية أخرى، فإن الشرق الأوسط الصيني
مختلف تمامًا الآن، وقد أحسنت الدوحة
باستضافة كأس العالم مما يعطي
معنى آخر للمنطقة على
المسرح العالمي وللصينيين الذين يحبون
فهم اللعبة، هناك
مناطق أخرى لزيارة
مصر مثل  إن أداء كمية كبيرة من
البنية التحتية في الأردن هو أحد الأمور الأخرى
التي كانت قادمة
ولكن على الأقل هذا التجديد لإعادة
تقديم نفسه مرة أخرى في التشكيل
أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى النظر إليه من خلال العديد
من العوامل المختلفة، حيث أصبحت السلامة والسلامة الآن
أولوية لأنه داخل الصين
تزدهر السياحة المحلية بسرعة فائقة
بينما يتم إغلاق المتاجر، لذلك يجب أيضًا على
المسافرين الصينيين أن يقولوا حسنًا إذا
شعرت بالنكهات ونمط
الحياة الفاخر وهناك الكثير من
الأماكن التي يمكن رؤيتها داخل بلدي، فهل لا يزال
لدي الرغبة في ذلك  اخرجوا، وهذا هو
المكان الذي يصبح فيه تأرجح البندول
مختلفًا،
وستكون الشركة هنا لتبقى
وهم هنا ليبقوا وينفقوا
وسيتحولون إلى مغتربين وهذا هو المكان الذي
تنمو فيه المنطقة بشكل هائل.
الجمال الآخر حول الأمينو  المنطقة
بسبب عدم وجود قيود على التأشيرة
وهذا أعطى دفعة كبيرة للمسافرين